ووفق خبراء تدير طالبان الان دوله ذات
حدود سهله للاختراق من سته جيران بلا جيش
نظامي وتعاني من عقوبات دوليه وهي غير
قادره على تلبيه توقعات الولايات المتحده
لمكافحه الارهاب الخبير بمجموعه الازمات
الدوليه جرام سميث قال ان مقاتلي حركه
طالبان باكستان يحتمون في افغانستان
ويهاجمون باكستان
طالبان من جهتها نفت ايواء الجماعات
المتطرفه داخل افغانستان مؤكده التزامها
بمنع التهديدات الامنيه للدول الاخرى
لكنها اقرت بفشلها في منع الهجمات
المتطرفه داخل افغانستان حيث قتل حاكم
طالبان في مقاطعه بلغ الشماليه في هجوم
الانتحار تبناه تنظيم داعش الاسبوع الماضي
وفي ديسمبر من عام 20 22 اعلن تنظيم داعش
مقتل مسؤولي سياسه المنطقه في مقاطعه
بتخشام الشماليه الشرقيه
منذ ثلاثه عقود والقلق ما زال يسود
الولايات المتحده بشان وجود مقاتلي
القاعده وقادتها بافغانستان
انخرطت الولايات المتحده في افغانستان بعد
هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر للبحث عن قاده
القاعده في اطول حرب خارجيه في تاريخ
امريكا في عام 2022 قتل زعيم القاعده اي
من الظواهري في كابول في غاره امريكيه
بطائره مسيره وهو امر رفضته طالبان بان
الظواهر قتل في كابول مسؤولون امريكيون
يقولون ان الزعيم القاعده الجديد سيف
العدل وهو ضابط سابق في القوات الخاصه
المصريه يتواجد في ايران وسط نافيين من
طهران